so here we are january 2022
year three of the covid i don't know
about you but i am weary trying to
figure this all out all of us just want
our lives back
tonight
we bring you three medical doctors with
clear and concise answers to the
questions you are all asking we want to
separate fact from fiction and help you
navigate this at issue
what are the rules
what are the risks
what is the science
are politics usurping the science and
when will this pandemic end
and as if the mixed messages and
misinformation from the white house
aren't enough
joe biden held a covet press conference
this week that served only to further
confuse the issues and to complicate
that in what appears to be a retreat on
his own mandates after the supreme court
oral arguments and the writing is on the
wall
listen to what joe says
uh no i don't think covert is here to
stay that having
coveted in the environment here and in
the world is probably here to stay but
covet as we're dealing with it now
is not here to stay the new normal
doesn't have to be
you may recall joe's promises when he
ran for president
i'll shut down the virus not the economy
and we can walk and chew gum at the same
time
you sure about that joe
walk and chew gum at the same time
joe with all due respect you've
displayed quite clearly that you are
barely even able to walk and you
certainly haven't shut down the virus
let alone even had a plan to shut it
down
folks the tragic irony of joe biden's
failure to make good on his campaign
promise is that more people died of
covid during his first year than under
president trump's entire time in office
even with vaccines in year three of the
outbreak under joe biden we don't even
have enough tests to find out if we have
covent or one of its variants in fact
they don't even put the order in on time
for test because they didn't even see it
coming
according to kamala harris quote
we didn't see omicron coming
and that's the nature of what this awful
this awful virus has been which as it
turns out has mutations and variants
and that echoed her clueless boss's
comments as well
the vice president said in recent days
that that you didn't see delta coming
you didn't see omicron coming
how did you get it wrong
i would get it wrong nobody saw it
coming
nobody in the whole world who saw it
coming
sadly our so-called leaders simply
aren't on the same page and their
confusion is only exacerbating this
crisis take a look
we did jake we definitely saw a variance
coming i think what one referred to what
was not anticipated was the extent
of the mutations and the amino acid
substitutions in omicron which is really
unprecedented that's something you would
not have anticipated but we certainly
were anticipating that they were going
to be varying
meanwhile as joe biden relentlessly
criticized president trump for his
handling of the pandemic joe now claims
there's simply no federal solution
well joe if there's no federal solution
why are there federal vaccine mandates
requiring that employees be fired if
they don't comply
this in spite of a medical or religious
exemption and in spite of the fact that
health care workers put their own lives
on the line working with patients when
they had no vaccine
this will all be resolved soon folks as
the united states supreme court just
heard oral arguments on the legality of
biden's vaccine mandate for large
employers and for health care workers a
decision likely to affect 80 million
americans
but make no mistake
this virus has affected each and every
one of us our children our moms and dads
brothers and sisters
co-workers and friends
the american people want the truth we
want solutions we want answers and
tonight
that's exactly what we will provide
and that's my open
let me know what you think on my
facebook and twitter
judge jeanine
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else